I don't think it made us who you are I
don't think it made us how much family
you have or heaven gotcha
it is a hard process we had no relatives
and no friends here it was a leap of
faith being a foreigner or being an
immigrant there's a lot to learn so
you'd better embrace it for a while when
we arrived I felt like a foreigner but
after a couple of years working there we
felt like we were part of the community
you know we've developed friendships
with with other Kiwis and and they treat
us just like everybody else you've got
to break away because the more we remain
and we have isolated pockets of groups
of ethnic groups it will be also very
hard for the Kiwis to break in I knew
that we had really really made progress
when some friends of ours called us
fauna that was amazing
but it took a lot of hard work and it
wasn't an easy not too great
[Music]